are you looking to save money on your
AWS bill but not too sure where to begin
well you've come to the right place
because in this video I'll be sharing
with you five simple ways to start
cutting down your Cloud expenses today
now these aren't just going to be random
tips these are tried and tested methods
I personally recommended to AWS
customers during my time as a Solutions
architect so whether you're new to AWS
or you've been working with Cloud for
some time now keep watching because
you're going to want to hear these
strategies okay here's the thing when it
comes to costing AWS it all boils down
to two main factors usage and rate the
cost of your AWS bill is equal to how
much you use multiply by the rate that
they charge and so you can either
optimize usage by making sure you're
only using what you need or you can
optimize for your rate by paying less
for what you use sounds interesting
right but before we dive into the top
five ways I want to give a quick shout
out to antimatter a company dedicated to
helping you significantly trim down your
AWS bill with anti-metal you could
effortlessly save up to 75 on AWS you
don't need any engineering skills and
you don't have to sign any contracts to
get started all it takes is one click
and 30 seconds to get your savings
automated we all love a good discount
from time to time but I think the way
anti-metal works is even more
interesting by using an AI model they
analyze a bunch of factors from your
account to make sure you get the most
out of every dollar that you spend all
you need to do is approve anti-metals
recommendations and they take care of
the rest during my two years as a
Solutions architect I came to realize
something many large companies who use
AWS actually have a team dedicated to
optimizing and managing their Cloud
expenses that's how important it is for
them to save money but if you're like me
and don't have a full team behind you
anti-metal can stand out as the go-to
solution oh and by the way antimatter is
free for all startups so make sure you
head over to antimetal.com forward slash
Tech with Lucy to get started with
reducing your AWS spill thank you
anti-metal for partnering with me on
this video okay so tip number one is to
delete unused resources this may sound
obvious but if you don't delete
resources that are no longer needed they
can quietly eat into your budget all
instances snapshots and volumes all of
this can quickly add up when I worked at
AWS I often saw clients neglect all
resources if they had taken the time to
monitor these resources they would have
been able to save a decent chunk of
their AWS Bill regularly monitoring your
resources and removing those that are
not in use can help you make sure you
don't waste any money this also applies
if you're a student or individual
developer you might discover that you
have temporary projects that you've
forgotten about still lingering in your
AWS account one tool I'd recommend for
this is the AWS trusted advisor it can
help you identify unused resources and
recommend ways to optimize your
infrastructure now if we think back to
our equation from early on cost equals
to usage multiplied by rate and so by
deleting unused resources we're directly
decreasing our usage which in turn
lowers our overall cost the next tip is
to right size your instances right
sizing is all about matching your
resources with the actual workload needs
you can kind of think of it like wearing
the right size shoes anything too big or
too small can be uncomfortable similarly
if you use instances that are larger
than what's required it can lead to
unnecessary costs so what we want to do
here is identify Resources with low
utilization by stopping or right sizing
these resources we can reduce the cost
for example let's say I'm using a t4g
large instance where my rate is about 67
cents per hour if I find out that I
actually just need a t4g medium instance
instead then my new rate goes down to
3.3 cents per hour which is only half of
what I paid for to identify
underutilized instances you can check
out the AWS cost Explorer a server set
lets you understand and manage your AWS
cost over time and this tip ties right
back to our formula cost equals to usage
times my rate by right sizing your
instances and bringing down the rate
you're able to directly lower the cost
my third tip is to reserve and commit
whenever possible reserving instances
and committing to them for the long term
can lead to significant cost savings AWS
offers reserved instances and savings
plans and both options can provide
massive discounts compared to the
standard on-demand pricing for
consistent workloads that you know will
be around for a while such as one to
three years reserving and committing
them can be a game changer you're
essentially buying in bulk and locking
them at a discounted rate as you can see
here with AWS savings plans you can save
up to 72 percent with a flexible pricing
model you can choose between compute ec2
and sagemaker plans but be careful
because over committee can actually end
up costing you more what I mean by this
is if you lock yourself into more
resources than you need then you might
find yourself stuck with unnecessary
expenses you may still be getting a
discount but you're spending more than
you have to the key here is to carefully
evaluate your long-term needs and only
commit to what you actually use another
way to optimize usage essay of costs is
to enable AWS Auto scaling Auto scaling
is all about automatically scaling your
resources to meet Demand by having AWS
automatically adjust your resource
levels up and down you can make sure
you're never over provisioning or
underprovisioning this way you only pay
for what you use Auto scaling is
available at no extra cost and once you
set it up you'll be able to find the
perfect balance between performance and
cost now tip number five is to schedule
on and off times for your resources if
you have any instances that don't need
to be running 24 7 then turning them off
is like turning off lights when you
leave a room it saves cost and it saves
energy for example if you have an
instance that only needs to run during
nine to five business hours on Monday to
Friday then you can save up to 70 by
stopping the instance during the
weekends and during the evenings one
useful tool for this is the AWS instant
scheduler it automatically handles the
scheduling process for you so that you
don't have to automatically turn your
instances on and off all right now that
we've covered the fundamental cost
saving strategies here are three bonus
tips that will help you save even more
on AWS in the long run the first one is
to utilize the AWS free tier whenever
possible this lets you experiment with
new ideas without spending any money the
second one is to stay up to date with
the latest changes in AWS services and
prices by keeping an eye out on what's
new you can take advantage of the
changes that could lower your cost and
bonus tip number three is to consider
leveraging third-party tools or
consulting services like anti-metal this
can offer a fresh perspective and help
you uncover heated insights so there you
have it five simple ways to save money
on your AWS Bill plus some bonus tips to
help you cut down your cost even more
don't forget to check out anti-metal in
the description below to leverage their
amazing for startups if you found this
video helpful please remember to give it
a like and as always I'll see you in the
next one bye for now
foreign